ok black game against GSP what could I
play let's let's maybe try the bangko
again oh gee 3 ok I'll take it yeah this
is somewhat strange no of course not
yeah just d5 keep it simple on now let's
try to play a bit more ambitiously its
last leg porn but very very active
position ok so he wants to own I to be 3
i'd like to make sure that he doesn't
pin on with the with Bishop g5 done it's
a it's a pretty active position can take
on c6 now but it's not sure that I need
to fear that yeah maybe if maybe Nyjah
for I can let's try for some some
technical tricks and it's not pointless
anyway as provoking this kind of mover
so is of some value
wow this looks like a very unnatural
move
hmm yeah which does necessarily mean
that there's a refutation that's
complete department I'm not sure one
idea that happens to take on d4 and
paper should be fire at some moment
came this is also should also be okay
that h3 hanging so he's not really able
to take d5
okay so i understand i cannot take here
takes d4 ed Knight f3 Bishop takes Queen
takes because of rupee aid and at the
end time I'm losing the Queen okay all
right this is still a position where I
need to be quick so I don't want to
waste any time here to attack before and
I still have fun a very good development
okay maybe I can can operate with Bishop
before here if it takes d5 h h 3 is
still on hanging and this is nice if i
can exchange it I came the should have
three the stroke of one so I need to get
back
9360 my idea so then whoopsie aid can
you have prevented that but I don't
really fear this position in any case my
pieces are active enough and he doesn't
really have much to play against always
attacking deform the only real concern
he has some my time deficit
is he threatening g4 takes take now you
should be fraught okay he's weakening
too much yeah in the slide ok so how to
continue let's group it back and then
decide what to do like to exchange the
LightSquared's quite bishops of course
maybe I can manage via be five
yeah I know it's a bit of a time
consuming wow ok time consuming
operation so it's a bit of a provocation
game it's it's not much happening really
but maybe you does some mistake to be
made also good to happen to me of course
so night on g7 yeah 28
it's all covered come on
I could be three now or not yeah but
this isn't bad as well
night age three ng one time warning yeah
still it's a piece check check
with what 12 seconds Joe didn't see that
one check
and yeah okay we'll lose on time just
yeah should i spend i spent too much
time around here so it doesn't help that
he that he blundered it all away but 30
seconds should be enough well not so
quick today it is probably not the best
technical um play anyway but of course
it should be sufficient if you have a
bit more time you can try to play it
more precisely but ok it's it's just a
win nothing more nothing less but yeah
you need to of course see Bishop a 6
this is a problem just dumb we should be
four if you just go here I should just
play play this white can can reside with
the clear conscience at least in an old
tongue control game you never never get
them can try that but with Bishop a six
at least um yeah maybe you can't align
that actually okay but I have this yeah
it should be it should be a win but i
can probably a player even more
precisely and before yeah thanks for
watching